case in point case in point real quick
there was Alex was supposed to go out on
a date with his girl right and then she
says that her car isn't working her car
breaks down or whatever and he's like
okay cool so now typically when a guy
would say if he has a functioning car
and what she's actually hinting at is
hey my car's broken down maybe your
car's not even broken down because what
she actually wants is for the guy to
come pick her up my man what did you say
to her
all right so what did you say to her in
the response after she said my car's not
working I said I if we need a reschedule
but there's backstory you know I know
but if you explain the backstory it'll
make it even funnier dude well the whole
thing for me is like when we set up this
day she hit me what she hit me with that
like oh I'll meet you there
so in my head immediately I might okay
she doesn't want me to pick her up
that's what I thought so my all right
[ __ ] all right so that all this [ __ ]
happened with a car and she's like yeah
you know my car's this my car is that
and I'm just like all right then bad
like I guess schedule and then her
response was yeah right so when we
finish the story so yeah so it was funny
because I was with Nick and David during
this time we we just went to it was like
Chinese New Year right or some [ __ ] yeah
yeah so then I remember telling them in
the car like on even both of them I even
texted my homie Patrick and he was like
eight offered it pick her up I'm like
nah nah she wants to drive so I'm not
gonna bro it was so set on that - yeah
so like later on the restaurant we were
supposed to go to actually went with my
mom right to go eat and I posted a
picture and she responded to it and I do
this a lot - what did she say she was
she just said damn right and I do this a
lot like in my head I'm like you know
what [ __ ] I'm a girlfriend let me see
what happens and I do that and then I'd
say about 90% of the time I still don't
do it but like there's like a 10% that I
feel it and then sauce I [ __ ] I'm
gonna see what she says so I'm like yeah
man
I could have just offered to pick you up
her response was yeah I definitely would
away that's exactly she was acting it
and that's the funny part it's like
that's that in and of itself encapsulate
how you are with women which is so
[ __ ] funny I got I get all my girls
that I've died and I've gotten so lucky
with because they started like I've
never yeah I've never had to like start
the relationship the girl I always came
on to me and like they kind of started
it up so I'm like [ __ ] this is good the
only problematic to speak and the reason
why I got a backup at this is because
like he talks about like his interaction
with women right and it's it's so odd
because of how awkward it is because he
can't get out of his own [ __ ] head
yeah which we always talk about this in
this podcast where there's a human being
where I I get messages it's not yours is
actually mild compared to some of these
other kids but sometimes like you have
these thoughts in your heads that kind
of just grow into this weird weird
thought of how bad things are gonna
happen and it never ever gets that way
and it's also we know who you are and we
know if I'm in person and it's like dude
you were so overthinking it for you I'm
not anything that's that's what I'm
saying this guy his first fight when he
found out when he told me who he was
fighting he was like all find his
big-ass black dude in my head I was like
oh [ __ ] he show me who the guy was and I
was like oh man this guy's six four alex
is like five seven five six and I was
like yo this [ __ ] big is [ __ ]
in my head I was like alright bro like
this is gonna be a trip but when I was
like how you feel he goes I'm fine and
usually when I hear people say I'm fine
I usually don't believe it but this time
I was like oh [ __ ] this dude is actually
like chill so it made me feel a way more
relaxed but the fact that this dude is
so calm when he's gonna fight another
human being in front of like hundreds of
people and then he can't even be like
hey I'll pick you up
that's how always the most ridiculous
thing ever I think it's that I don't
know it's like I've never been confident
in myself in my look
basically was my looks like growing up
like I was like I I don't feel a dude I
was always kind of chunky I just never
had the confidence so like talking to
girls was always something more it was
terrifying to me and there would be so
many situations where like like if
someone else was watching it they'd be
like yo that was like an opportunity and
I would just it would what what are you
scared of though is the question you
know I honestly I think I've been scared
so long I don't even know what I'm
saying I think it's everything it's like
you know growing up I was scared of
getting rejected I was for some reason
scared that they were gonna say no and
then everybody was gonna find out and
then I'm the laughingstock of all this
girl turned him down laughingstock see
see now this is what I want to bring up
and I knew that [ __ ] was gonna come on
now I'm gonna use his girl